last twist name the remake of the
groundbreaking Halloween hurts his
treats hot daughter the death the Hilda
hides every bill
it's one of those right welcome to your
weekly ticket at home edition all right
let's start you out with some incredible
news because Academy Award winner Tycho
white TD is set to direct and co-write a
Star Wars feature for theatrical release
of course taiga is no stranger to Star
Wars having directed the finale of the
mandalorian on Disney Plus Christie
Wilson Cairns who co-wrote the
screenplay for 1917 and was also
nominated for an Oscar last year will
co-write white TV Star Wars film
Walt Disney Pictures currently has three
Star Wars movies scheduled for December
in the years 2022
2024 and 2026 but it's unclear which
year Whitey's film might be released M
night Shyamalan has set the cast for his
upcoming untitled Universal movie with
Eliza Scanlon Thomas and Mackenzie Aaron
Pierre Alex wolf and Vicky creeps
Shyamalan will be writing producing and
directing the untitled film plot details
are tightly under wraps but Shyamalan
last three self financed films have
grossed six hundred million dollars
worldwide on a combined thirty-five
million dollar budget
all right Sean on ICU and nearly a
decade after scream four hit theaters in
2011 the slasher franchise star Neve
Campbell says she's currently
negotiating her return for scream 5 in
an interview with Rotten Tomatoes
Campbell said we're having conversations
I've been approached about it the
project will be directed by Matt Benton
Ellie open and Tyler galette the
co-directors of 29 teens ready or not oh
that's like perfect that's that's like
the perfect directing due out nice nice
now if you're looking for a suggestion
as to what to watch well look no further
I've got a special guest for you today
Rotten Tomatoes editor-in-chief Joel
Mears who's got some recommendations for
us what he got for us Joel good ok well
I've got two films to recommend today
one of them is brand spanking new and
one of them came out last year the first
one is blue story it's brand new from a
UK filmmaker called rat man he is a
former rapper obviously and this is his
writing and directing debut and it's
about two young men caught up in gang
warfare on the streets of London they
started out as great friends but then as
the story progresses they're sort of
torn apart it's really sort of
suspenseful but engaging gripping funny
at times and it's a great day boot from
rap man who actually appears in the film
throughout as a kind of Greek chorus he
literally comes on screen and starts
rapping to tell you about what's going
on in the story and just speed it up so
it's a really interesting different take
and I think it's an insight into a
culture that most people won't be
familiar with in the States
Oh awesome so I mean like I guess if you
like was it Hamilton that sort of
storytelling yeah well they're the
characters themselves aren't rapping
they have a naturalistic sort of
situation but then suddenly rap men will
come on in the background every sort of
20 minutes and move the narrative
forward and sort of comment on what's
happening in really insightful ways but
if you do like Hamilton if you do like
Goodfellas but you're also sort of into
more contemporary crime dramas this is a
film that I think people will enjoy what
else you got so my second film is I've
always got to pay respect to my homeland
it's a film from Australia called top
end wedding came out last year it's a
beautiful romantic comedy about a young
woman who's about to marry a guy takes
him home to meet the family in Darwin in
the Northern Territory which is known
colloquially as the top end of Australia
when she gets there she find that her
mother's left her father and so she's on
this journey to find her mother while
also organizing a wedding it's very
funny very romantic and a little bit
like blue story it's gonna give people
an inside of a little culture that they
may not be overly familiar with because
the central family the bride and her
mother or digitus Australians the mother
was originally from the tiwiii islands
off the north coast of Australia so we
get to spend a lot of time
we and around sort of indigenous culture
and it's just missing gorgeous moments
gorgeous scenes and shout out to believe
actress Miranda Topsail who is just
charming as hell she's amazing Wow Joel
with some really cultured
recommendations thanks for bringing I
this and my glasses on and well there
you have it make sure to check those out
Joel thank you so much Mary thanks Kyle
have a great one available to watch at
home today Capone
[Music]
[Applause]
Tom Hardy stars in this film based on
the true story about the life of
Alphonso Capone once a ruthless
businessman who ruled Chicago with an
iron fist Al Capone was the most
infamous and feared gangster of American
lore at the age of 47 following nearly a
decade of imprisonment dementia rots
Alphonsus mine and his past becomes his
present harrowing memories of his
violent and brutal origins melt into his
waking life as he spends his final years
surrounded by family with the FBI lying
in wait he struggles to place the memory
of the location of millions of dollars
he hid away on his property did he check
the couch cushions that's an old joke
it's too old and available to watch at
home on Friday Scoob do you realize
where we are look a real man the clean
modernist thing the cool blue color
palette we're in did you say IKEA nope
I said Falcon fury just like you Scoob
reveals how long time friend Scooby and
Shaggy first met and how they joined
with young detectives Fred Velma and
Daphne to form the famous mystery Inc
now with hundreds of cases solved and
adventures shared Scooby and the gang
face their biggest most challenging
mystery ever a plot to unleash the Ghost
Dog Cerberus upon the world as they race
to stop as global dog pocalypse the gang
discovers that Scooby has a secret
legacy and an epic destiny greater than
anyone imagined the film is directed by
Tony servo nee and has an all-star cast
including Will Forte as shaggy Zac Efron
is Fred Gina Rodriguez as Velma and
Amanda Seyfried as Daphne all right just
a tiny bit look well that's it for this
week let us know in the comments what
you'll be watching or if you'll be
watching Capone or Scoob well I'm Cal
nonnamous and I'll see you next week
I'll leave it long for now
[Music]